[Musique]
e
quel est le point commun entre ces
terrains de handball la source
joinville
c'est ici que les meilleur handballeur
du monde se sont formés et ce week-end à
cologne un événement historique a lieu
sur la planète handball sur les quatre
clubs en demi finale trois sont français
nicolas claire daniel narcisse benoît
culte kung et melvin richardson sono
digne représentant mais malgré les
championnats du monde ou encore les jeux
olympiques
l'ancien président de la ligue n'est pas
blasé pour autant de ta bulle
l'éditorial du président comment ils
commencent permet même si on a eu des
résultats on a eu des soucis c'est parce
que faut pas les oublier on a eu des des
jeux en équipe de france et des joueurs
on n'est jamais blasé puis à durban le
réunionnais si affaire du soir
réunionnais d'un sens où on l'a montré
en montre et on va montrer en compte
à la réunion on peut sentir on a sorti
des champions car tous les domaines que
ça sport ou autre on peut encore sortir
si on nous endort si on continue à nous
les moyens
depuis les années 70 c'est la création
de la ligue
ce sport est exemplaire dans sa
structuration je crois que c'est le
fruit du travail viande des clubs
john barnes général de détection de
formation et européens à moi de la
réunion pour le handball le premier sang
de haut niveau c'était nous le pôle
espoir on en a deux ça ne vient pas
comme ça il ya tout un travail qui est
fait d y est le formation de cadres de
d'obligations par rapport aux aux jeunes
par rapport au club depuis toujours il
ya eu cet état d'esprit ce sont deux
philosophies du handball qui a été mis
en place par les anciens dirigeants et
que j'ai essayé deux avec les dirigeants
actuellement et alfie les pluies
continuent de garder développer un autre
événement aura lieu car ces matchs
représentent les dernières sorties
officielles de daniel narcisse membres
d'une première promotion de pôles
espoirs handball financé par le
département lui les autres ont bénéficié
d' aide financière de la collectivité
avant de devenir professionnel avant de
prendre leur envol
ils ont beaucoup de mérite d'avoir pu
accéder au haut niveau n'oublieront pas
ce sont des jeunes qui ont progressé
dans les clubs
la réunion qui sont projetés pour
franchir la mer est aujourd'hui réussi a
donc un beau parcours dans les clubs de
métropole donc je lui ai dit pleine
réussite et c'est la preuve que à la
réunion nous avons atteint d'excellence
c'est la preuve que quand on veut on
réussit et le département participe à la
réussite de ces jeunes et je dirais une
mention particulière à daniel narcisse
puisque il a décidé après une longue
carrière de mettre fin justement cette
carrière c'est pour lui et pour nous
tous un grand événement en ce qui va
sortir pour cette grande finale et aussi
aux trois autres plus jeunes
quel bel exemple que de suivre les
traces de daniel narcisse
nous sommes à vos côtés la réunion est à
vos côtés pour vous voir réussir
pleinement ces finales nicolas benoit
daniele melvin le fils jackson vont
animer le handball européen ce week-end
du quoi donner beaucoup de fierté à
notre département
[Musique]